so now that net neutrality has been
rolled back the FCC is blocking a law
enforcement investigation into suspected
comment fraud despite the fact that at
least one actual senator was
impersonated in what is just abundantly
clear rampant comment fraud and the lead
up to the repeal of net neutrality by
the FCC
so the backstory on this is that
supposedly the FCC received just tons
and tons of comments against net
neutrality or set a different way
the FCC received a ton of comments in
favor of repealing net neutrality which
never really made sense it didn't even
pass the sniff test because we know that
public opinion is overwhelmingly in
favor of net neutrality and you'd have
to believe that the small portion of the
population opposed to it was so strongly
opposed to it that they in insanely
disproportionate numbers were the ones
writing to the FCC of course the truth
is that we've seen data analyses done by
mathematicians language analyses and it
appears that there was a major amount of
fraud and fake comments supporting the
repeal of net neutrality well that's
something we would want to investigate
right well not according to the FCC the
FCC is blocking this investigation you
have New York Attorney General Eric
Schneiderman who's trying to investigate
but the FCC is not giving them anything
it's not giving them any of what they
need to actually figure out what the
hell happened here to quote our fearless
orange leader a Schneiderman wrote a
letter saying that they're getting no
help from the FCC an FCC lawyer wrote
back saying yeah we have no interest in
helping law enforcement period they
imply the entire investigation would be
irrelevant anyway and they're actually
trying to use the argument of privacy at
least in part to resist helping in this
investigation they said listen your
staff has previously asked us to provide
logs of IP addresses for some of these
comments if we give you IP addresses of
public commenters we would be
potentially exposing their identity
which would be a privacy concern which
is hilarious that all of a sudden now
the FCC's number-one priority is privacy
in the meantime just to put a fine point
on just how insane this comment fraud
situation is Senator Jeff Merkley found
out he's a Democrat he found out that he
was impersonated during the FCC comment
period and that under his name an anti
net neutrality comment was submitted
which is just insane because he's a
public official with an on-the-record
position in favor of net neutrality he
tweeted yesterday turns out someone
impersonated me during the FCC net
neutrality comment period further proof
of forged comments in this process we
need to get to the bottom of this and
demand justice for those who sought to
be heard
check out the comment that was submitted
under his name which we'll put up on the
screen for you here under his name the
eff a comment was submitted where he
supposedly said the FCC's net neutrality
rules were written in the Obama White
House by political staff and tech
industry special interests who overruled
the FCC's own experts the FCC's own
chief economist Tim Brennan called the
rules an economics free zone they should
be repealed that sure sounds like
something Democratic Senator Jeff
Merkley would say ha so what's the
situation either this is some kind of
troll or this was done in such massive
numbers this comment fraud that murkly's
identity was caught up alongside
millions of others and used for these
fraudulent comments I don't know how his
name in particular became wrapped up in
this but this is the real voter fraud
that Republicans have been talking about
it's not people voting twice it's not
dead people voting in presidential
elections it's not Massachusetts boat
voters being bused into New Hampshire to
vote for Hillary Clinton it's millions
of fake comments purporting to support
net neutrality the FCC here is
functioning as if they're above the law
they shouldn't be above the law and New
York Attorney General Eric Schneiderman
will hopefully keep the pressure on here
and you can actually get involved here
I've said before what we really need to
do is vote them out
that's going to be the real way to
reinstate net neutrality and we're
taught we'll talk after in the show
about a couple other things that are
going on but you've got to vote them out
but in the interim
call your Attorney General in your state
you can just Google who is my attorney
general or use the link in the sources
for the YouTube clip for this story
call your Attorney General and demand an
investigation into this because I assure
you even though it won't get net
neutrality reinstated if you can tie up
the FCC with investigations by attorneys
general nationwide it's not going to be
good for them and that's exactly what we
should be looking to do the video you
just finished watching was made possible
by you through the membership program
you can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership